can I run a 5k and a full suit of
stormtrooper armor let's find out I need
oxygen the issue is that this armor is
really uncomfortable and leaves you with
basically no Mobility I can't even lean
over but I had to try
here's the game plan I'm gonna try to
break 30 minutes by sticking with the 9
Minute per mile group and if I fall
behind I just have to make sure that the
10 minute group doesn't catch up to me
at the first mile I came in at 903 a lot
faster than I needed to be to meet my
goal of 30 minutes and then disaster
struck disaster my crush plate
we're just gonna run with it unhooked I
can't fix it right now at Mile 2 my Pace
was still pretty good 9 17. but I was
beginning to feel the effects of the
armor and the lack of oxygen in the
helmet I think I need to slow it down a
little more on oxygen starting to see
rings of black a little bit as I needed
the end I thought back to everything
that led up to this moment and I knew I
had it in me to finish oh my gosh
of course they put a hill at the end
now I finally had an answer to the
question